and now we turn to the next topic which
will reveal us that some hidden messages
are more surprising than others after we
implemented the frequent words problem
let's apply to real genomes and let's
start from the replication of origin in
the bacterium vibrio cholerae and when
we ran our algorithms out there are too
many potential replication origins they
actually find for frequent words not to
mention that we don't know yet
was it's even statistically surprising
to find a 9-mer in a string of length
500 that appears three or more times so
of each of this four represents real
dnaa box and which of them are just
statistical artifacts well in this case
it's actually possible to figure out
which of these 4 candidates represent
real DNA box because two of them are
very special they represent
complementary reverse complementary
k-mers and here i showed that one of
them actually is a perfect reverse
complement to us you may think that I'm
cheating because if you look at the red
nightmares in the Box shown in the box
and the red name are shown in the bottom
side of the slides a different but
remember DNA has directions and strands
run in opposite directions so when we
look at the string starting from TAC red
straight you should actually read it in
the opposite direction and then
everything would make sense so hidden
message found and it is extremely
surprising almost unbelievable to find
one word appearing six times Isis itself
or as a reverse complement in a short
strength so it reinforced our believes
that we are on subject and after we've
done it let's try something else let's
try to find hidden message in Jeremy
toga petrol fella who
which is a bacteria enjoying life in a
very hot environment about 80 degrees
Celsius
maybe we should simply look for this to
Kaymer's that we found before but
unfortunately they are not even there so
it looks like we need to run our
frequent words problem again and in this
case they actually find six frequent
words and which tells us that probably
different genomes have different hidden
messages it complicates our life quite a
lot because for thousands of bacteria we
need to search for new and new hidden
messages but to this frequent words
problem VI at least armed to these
algorithms
to do it for any bacteria now let's
consult to choose with each one of the
six nine Mars represents real dnaa box
let's consult Ori finder software which
tells us that it looks like the one
shown on this slide and we learned
therefore how to find frequent words and
hopefully dnaa boxes in any bacteria but
wait a second I told you how to find DNA
a boxes as frequent words if origin of
replication is known but of course the
position of the origin of applications
is 500 nucleotide regions where we look
for frequent roots is unknown how
possibly we can find it remember we have
to find this 500 nucleotide regions in
genomes that maybe millions of
nucleotide long and let's resort resort
to the idea that I call clumps or
clusters of hidden messages to solve
this problem so what we were doing
before we assume that replication origin
regions maybe 500 nucleotide long is
known and in this replication origins we
will find in frequent words for example
in this window we found four frequent
words that
four times so it gives some gives us a
hint that maybe it is a DNA box but if
we don't know replication origin of what
should we do maybe you should look at
all possible windows in the genome and
if in a particular then do we find many
we find some frequent words appearing
many times it's a hint that maybe we
found a replication origin
well let's define short or as something
confluence l and many is at least T
times and that defines the notion of LT
clump
it's a k-mer that appear in window of
length L at least ter time T times and
now you have a new Rosalind challenge
which is Clum finding problem you are
given a stream called genome and integer
K the lens of Kaymer and integer l Vindu
lens and t number of patterns in club in
output you have to find all LT clumps in
the genome and we hope that every LT
club will point us to the location of
replication origin let's assume that you
solve it and let's run it let's run it
on ecology know the workhorse of
bacterial genomics here's the result we
find about two thousand potential five
hundred three clubs which means five
hundred wind lands in doe where there
are frequent words appearing three or
more times it is just too many
it's absolutely unclear how to choose
the real replication origin among exam
what should we do should we give up
let's try to see let's try to develop
new ideas and see how we can move
further despite the fact that we seem to
be stuck